I do still have yes there are still
there are still Swedish berries
okay so so what I what I need so I'm
gonna need you I need you to sit there I
need you just sit there and and I'm I'm
going to try to explain this movie to
you and now I okay do you want me to
start with the sequel bate ending maid
Marian's titty costumes or the extended
description of the Sheriff of Nottingham
being raped with a broomstick when he
was a child
oh how about the opening were see like
this the movie basically starts as it
zero-dark Locksley the hurt Locksley
Robin of Locksley is long half time walk
finding saving private Locksley
you know it's it's it's the Sicario
prequel we didn't want or need the it's
it's Sicario 1282 the thin red Locksley
Fullmetal Locksley not just a war see
there is a there is a a semi-automatic
ballista the that is there there is a
sequence okay okay every war movie since
Saving Private Ryan has a scene where
like the entire squad is pinned down by
machine-gun fire and they're like hiding
behind like pillars and they've got like
like use a mirror to try to where is he
I can't oh and then they gotta like do a
flanking maneuver yeah there's that
except they're pinned down in they
they're pinned down by fire from a
ballista that can fire like six bolts a
second just like and they're like end
and it's even you know you've you've got
the tower it's got a dome and there's
like a crack in it and the bliss is like
set in that and then they're down and
like this this like open square they're
like like pinned behind like tiny
pillars and they try to like look at it
in the reflection of it oh yeah and and
and all of their all of their armor so
they're wearing like the bar dish you
know so leather jacket with just like
you know metal plates sewn onto it
except it has been intentionally
designed to match like the quilting of a
modern flak jacket they're they're
wearing medieval eyes modern stuff and
this goes through the entire thing like
really had their hearts to settle for
Robin Hood
now there's a a stylization to it that
is is I want to like the stylization I
do want to like the stylization like
it's it's it's got a sort of V for
Vendetta vibe to a lot of it in that
there's sort of an unreality to it and
that that's it's it's weird but it's not
necessarily bad where where it's just
straight up bad is when you get to like
the acting and the writing and trying to
act at the writing no it's this is this
movie was made by Garth merengue this is
a Garth meringue G's Darkplace movie
like I know writers who use subtext and
they're all cowards at
multiple like multiple multiple times
throughout the movie characters just
straight up they exactly like so so
there's this whole plot where like Robin
where Robin needs to infiltrate a
meeting between the Sheriff of
Nottingham and the Cardinal and so rah
like it's okay so Robin gets back from
the Crusades gets back from the war
stuff happens and he cooks up this plant
well actually Jamie Foxx's character to
remember Morgan Freeman's character from
from Prince of Thieves
yeah so he that character has been
merged with Little John okay and there's
two gags where so he's a moor and has
thus a name that I cannot confirm the
veracity of but it is either Moorish or
Arabic or or is it as close as the
writers cared to get and there are
multiple instances of a gag very like
the old hacky gag where it's like what's
your name
and then all of the english-speaking
characters like struggle to struggle to
say it and he was just like I will just
translate it into your language you may
call me John
and then they reused that at the end
where Friar Tuck who speaks Arabic you
know it's like what's your name it's
like how about I just translated and
call you John and then that's like the
the dip to black for the first couple
titles before it then comes back in for
the big sequel bait reveal that Jamie
Dornan is now the actual Sheriff of
Nottingham
and that this is like this is this is
this is Batman Begins Robin Hood
addition there's a chi well I mean
Sharon like so there's it's a title so a
Sheriff of Nottingham someone else
claims the title and it sends to be
Sheriff of Nottingham - yes so Robin
comes back from the war and Marian is
now married or shacked up with this dude
Jamie Dornan who is I guess trying to be
like a people's revolutionary
or something it's very unclear what his
like goals are but will Scarlett yeah
and he so in the climax in the climax he
sees Marian and Robin kiss and then in
in the epilogue the Cardinal promotes
him to sheriff because he now hates
Robin and so the movie ends with like
Robin and Marian and the gang going out
into Sherwood Forest and so so the end
of the movie is like the status is the
setup for the like status quo of yes yes
yes so so Robins doing this whole like
he's playing both sides he's like
robbing he's like robbing the the the
collection plate at church but he's also
like but then during the day he's like
schmoozing as as Robin of Locksley has a
noble and you know
man yeah they're the the scene in the
dark night the dinner scene where
they're all talking and you know it in
the context of the dark night it ends up
being this interesting little
philosophical conversation and a chance
for the movie to engage with like the
philosophical idea of Batman and have
characters voice different perspectives
on it they try to recreate that in a
scene where the sheriff throws a party
for the Cardinal and it's like a
gambling hall and they're all playing
craps in 1282 like standing around it's
like a craps table
like I've said like the stylization is
weird but I'm kind of okay I want to
like the stylization
yeah you know it's it's oh so they're
trying to recreate that the Dark Knight
conversation except the dialogue is just
so hack it's just it's so clumsy and bad
and like on the nose like characters are
just like it's like well sheriff it
takes a thief to catch a thief and and
it's like and the whole reason ok Marian
isn't so Marian isn't a noble in her own
right in this one she's a peasant so the
whole reason she's at this party is
because Friar Tuck convinces convinces
the sheriff to send a few invitations to
important people
um it's amongst the peasantry which is
why Marian and Will are there it's an
excuse it's an excuse to get some it's
an excuse to have them there and but
that
makes it even weirder because it's like
because there's multiple scenes where
there is a scene okay
the sheriff says out loud they're not my
people they're my subjects in in one
scene and and yet he also tolerates a
tremendous amount a tremendous amount of
insolence from like the it's it's it's
very just not clear where it's going but
okay so I was saying there's this
meeting between the cardinal and and the
sheriff that Robin needs to infiltrate
and he infiltrates it and he has to like
he he sells out Friar Tuck it's it's a
ruse he does or he does a ruse and
infiltrates the infiltrates the meeting
and they say welcome to the big table
now as they like close the doors on the
on the private secret beating and then
the moment the doors are closed it is in
in like three seconds of dialogue okay
so we're going it's like all right so
everything is on track with our plan
that you and I have cooked up to fund
the Arabian army so that they will
defeat the English to destabilize the
country so that we can seize the crown
and the only reason our conspiracy in
our long-running in our like decade-long
conspiracy to destabilize a nation and
seize power I won't even touch the so
that's their plan
okay and the cardinal and the sheriff
so the cardinal and the sheriff are
conspiring to fund the other side of
the Crusades who wouldn't be Saladin's
army it would be it would be he was the
one who fought Richard Lionheart okay so
yes so they don't they don't say yeah
we're since we don't quite know where
the time line this actually is since
this is a set up but yes there they are
funding their funding therefore they're
funding the Muslims as though as though
the England had any wealth at that time
comparable whatsoever to just roll with
it
so they're funding the Muslims to to so
that the Muslims will defeat the English
army specifically thus destabilizing
Richards claim to power allowing the
Sheriff of Nottingham to was there any
Prince John anywhere in this no okay I
guess they're saving the first shot you
see of Maid Marion it's like okay so
she's she's dressed she's dressed like
he you know the outfit that Prince
Jasmine wears when she sneaks out of the
palace at the beginning of Aladdin she's
dressed like that except okay she's
dressed like that and she like it crawls
through this window into the stable to
steal a horse but then she turns around
and like the front of her bodice is just
like this deep v-neck with like Criss
crossing laces holding it together and
she's then then Robyn comes in is like
and they have this meet-cute where she's
trying to steal a horse because like her
neighbor's horse died and without a
horse to plow their fields they're all
gonna starve and he's like well the it's
like you can just steal my horse I'll
just let you have my horse you can just
you can just steal it like you've stolen
my heart on
and then they start making out and then
there's an extended montage where they
make out and then Robbins gets drafted
and the draft letter so the the
stylization starts subtly he gets this
draft letter and the whole thing is like
is like an illuminated manuscript it's
giant Germanic calligraphy fought like
all down the all down by the order of
the Sheriff of Nottingham text would
just be his liege lord calling all his
you know subordinate Lords yeah it'd
just be a page show you're like your
lord has summoned you you can't read
anyway so you must reading is for
priests and so he gets that so he goes
off to war then you get zero dark locks
sleep for like ten minutes and yes that
coat is amazing and and as you can see
like extremely V for Vendetta yeah like
all these guards oh yeah thee oh and
they've got riot shields they've got
leather riot shields like modern police
riot shields like like I said like
there's there's elements to the
stylization that I want to like and the
whole like it tries really hard to be
about like how the government like how
the wealthy are basically just like
exploiting the poor and funding wars for
their own for for their own purposes and
you you know it's it's this kind of like
rise up eat the rich sort of thing but
it's so clumsy and ham-handed and and
really does end up delving into like
just full-on conspiracy theory territory
with the whole
you know oh the the sheriff is the
sheriff and the church are secretly
funding the other side so that they can
take power and and it's not about so it
tries to be about wealth inequality but
really it's about oh well there's some
bad rich people and we got to watch out
for the bad rich people and the only
person who can start a bad rich the only
person even start a bad rich person is a
good rich person yeah yeah yeah oh every
single one has just like it ranges
between tasteful and absurd amounts of
cleavage there's a Jamie Foxx is in this
movie and he loses his hand during
zero-dark Locksley and then because so
Robin tries to save Jane Robin tries to
save John's son from getting beheaded by
[Music]
[ __ ] drill sergeant type and okay so
there's a character in this that it is
basically just soap from the modern
warfare call of duty games okay like he
is pretty much just the character of
soap you know he's even got he's got the
mustache and you know dresses in
tactical black and it's it's very very
strange but so raw Robin tries to save
John's son from getting beheaded but he
gets he gets killed and so and then
there's like I don't know
or riot of some kind the action is very
poorly shot and it's difficult to tell
what happens but John ends up getting
away Stow's away on the boat so they
threw it like Robin gets injured so they
throw him on a boat to send him back to
England John snows away on the boat and
like stalks Robin and then is like you
see everything that is wrong with your
home I'm going to teach you to be Batman
and then there's an extended mod Little
John is yeah a little-little John the
the role of the role of Ra's al Ghul
will be played by Little John who is
Jamie Foxx and and then there's this
extended montage that okay you know the
montage you know the training montage in
Batman V Superman that everyone makes
fun of yeah where Bruce Wayne is just
like Oh I'm so dark and angry I'm gonna
lift chains I'm gonna flip tires yeah
they do that and everybody walks around
with their bows like their m16s there's
like three swords in the entire movie
everyone's either using a bow or a
crossbow yep oh yeah they've got they
have Newports windows in them oh yeah
during during that whole sequence the
Molotov cocktails come out oh yeah and
like they've got Molotov cocktails and
oh yeah and everybody's like there's
there's a character wearing a bandana
with like like with like the skull with
this it's
that that's sort of mashup style you
work better in a comedy like now I'm
thinking about I'm thinking about the
Mel Brooks from a parody nothing you
like if you want to have your bizarre
medieval stylized you know stuff it
can't be in a movie that's also trying
to take itself seriously it it ends up
being a lot like I threw out it I was
thinking ultraviolet you know one of
those movies that has like an element of
just like absurdly overwrought
stylization that's trying just like way
too hard but then there isn't some other
hook to really get you to buy in you
know if you're going to compare like
ultraviolet to V for Vendetta or if
you're going to compare like literally
anything to the output of Baz Luhrmann
you know you it's just it's missing that
extra a little bit and the fact that
like the script is so bad and the
characters are like unmemorable and
they're the there's a whole chase scene
there's an extended chase scene where
the green screen compositing is some of
the worst I've seen since
honestly like spawn like it it it just
looks so much it looks so flat and you
you can tell the Sheikh has been added
in post because like there's there's
just that little difference like the
perspective doesn't change so everything
just like slides around but it slides
around like way too smooth and
mechanically you know they it's it's
they so they added camera shake in post
but the camera shake has no rhyme or
reason to it and it's just it's just
kind of floating floating there and it
and so that combined with the fact that
everybody just looks like paper cutouts
in front of in a diorama is
[Music]
it makes it pretty bad and the sequence
goes on for like quite a while so it's
not just like oh here's a shot that like
I don't know it's a quick shot they did
what they had to but it's like it keeps
coming back to these composite shots
like over and over for a very long time
and so you get a lot of time to keep
reevaluating how good that matting is I
feel I feel like there's a ton that I'm
missing or like that I'm just like
forgetting to mention okay wait wait
wait
okay Friar Tuck is played by Tim Minchin
the the comedian musician and he's
probably actually like the most charming
person the cast because Tim mentioned
just like exudes charisma he's a he's a
very trifle but he's he ends up being
out of place and yeah so he's he's the
comic relief and they've basically it's
like they wrote the role for Simon Pegg
but they could only get Tim Minchin and
I don't want that to sound like a slight
against Tim mentioned but it would be a
budgetary
for budgetary reasons the part of Simon
Pegg will be played by Tim Minchin and I
don't know like if there's he's okay he
keeps everybody has a plot everybody has
a plot or a scheme that like no they're
all keeping secret that just reminded me
of another scene that like makes gnosis
so okay after robbing his first scene
back in Nottingham he goes back to his
Manor we just kind of like busted up cuz
like it got trashed while he was gone
and like Marian comes by to
and she's like standing of the doorway
like Robin are you there
Robin Robin and and John is like you
can't you know it's like she can't know
anything about our plans to like you
know to play both sides against the
against the sheriff like she can't know
that we're gonna be like stealing from
him but also like you know doing this
like you you need to be Robin of
Locksley the aristocrat to her and it's
like okay so he's gonna go downstairs
and like just play it up so he starts
movie and then John grabs him again is
like you can't go down there
cuz reasons and and it's it's really
just an excuse to like not have her
involved for whatever reason but then
the reason is that if she were involved
like cuz because she and Friar Tuck are
also conspiring to do something don't
know what but they're conspiring to do
something well I I dunno why cuz I saw
the rest of it so like they keep it they
keep it secret for quite a long time but
then she's also keeping secrets from
[Music]
Jamie Dornan who himself also has
nebulous plans that basically sound like
it's it's it's very strange it's kind of
this of all of the Anna Crenn isms the
one where Jamie Dornan is basically
planning to like start a constitutional
democracy is the one that bugged me the
most
like that's Pretz the one that actually
kind of made me going wait what you know
the coats the like the clothing the
everybody the the big Vegas party all of
that you know I was like okay there's
like I'm gonna start a constitutional
republic and Nottingham
I don't know that's the one that kind of
kind of Gavi also that then he becomes
like this like political revolutionary
who at the very end turns into the the
fascist Sheriff of Nottingham because
his girlfriend hooked up with her ex
even though he was like 100 percent on
board with her with their rebellion
until until the moment that he's like no
no my girl kissed another man
she is spoiled forever I'm gonna become
the villain show you
oh also he gets like his ear burnt off
so there's like a whole two-faced reveal
the Batman parallels just keep going
like they really just keep going Friar
Tuck and Maid Marian have their plan
their plot like their plot which
basically they're looking for
essentially the same information as as
Robin and John are except they actually
know what they're looking for where
Robin and John are still at the stage of
like we need to figure out what's going
on even though the answer is just like I
don't know yeah that's the reason why
they can't tell otherwise they would
have to basically jump over an entire
stage of the plot yeah so so tuck and
Marian are already on the stage of
figuring out what we're basically
proving that there is a conspiracy and
so during the party they break into some
room full of documents and find a bunch
they're basically they find a bunch of
like Ledger's in Arabic they're
basically just straight-up like okay
seven thousand troops and here's here's
how much money we're going to pay for
these seven thousand troops signed by
the Sheriff of Nottingham and I will
keep that in my in my filing cabinet
with the rest of my important documents
gotta leave a paper trail
on this you want to get a receipt when
you're dealing with the Turks I tell you
what it's the whole conspiracy plot that
ultimately just like drives me the the
that I think tips me over the edge
because one it's like very ham-handed is
very poorly handled all of the villains
are like mustache twirling and just like
say exactly what they're everybody just
says exactly what they're thinking
there's multiple times it's like he's
like no Robin I know the real you
you're the hood Locksley is the disguise
and it's like I know writers Hugh
subtext and they're all cowards
but then it's it's like what what's the
sheriff's what's the sheriff's plan it's
like well he's got this convoluted plan
to like undermine for it's like just
money like they can't just make the
acquisition of money they can't just
hoarding wealth they can't just leave it
at hoarding well because that would just
then condemn Robin because oh he's
willing to sell information about the
English to the other side for money or
he's willing to but then he would be
getting money from he would then be
getting money from the Turks instead of
taking all of the money from the people
of Nottingham and putting the money to
evil evil uses yeah yeah the the simple
acquisition of wealth can't be the
problem because that would condemn Robin
for being you know a wealthy person in a
feudal system where like he basically
straight-up owns people the movie is
very sure not to not to condemn Robin
for his vast wealth so yeah so Robin
Hood
Sicario 2082 1282 zero-dark Loxley I I
compiled many I compiled many of them
yeah